euh chaque hiver des crèches de Noël
sont installées dans des hôtels de ville
malgré la loi de la séparation de
l'Église et de l'État c'est notamment le
cas à
Bézier qui est chaque année retoqué et
qui va une nouvelle fois inaugurer sa
crèche dans une semaine pour Noël 2023
on vous a préparé un rap doit-on pouvoir
installer des crèches de Noël dans les
mairies oui non vous répondez également
chez vous les chériis merci
[Musique]
regardez ce weekend de la commune de
Bézier s'apprête à inaugurer sa
traditionnelle crèche de Noël au sein de
h de
ville une crèche qui crée depuis
plusieurs années la polémique jugé
contraire au principe de laïcité des
institutions de la République et non
conforme à la loi de 1905 sur la
séparation de l'Église et de l'État le
tribunal administratif de Montpellier
avait notamment sommé l'année dernière
Robert Menard de la retirer on obéit
mais je regrette cette mesure qui est
d'une grande brutalité face à quelque
chose qui pourtant rassemble et cette
année à quelques jours de son
inauguration une plainte contre la
mairie de Bézier aurait désormais était
déposé pour protester contre cette
crèche alors doit-on pouvoir installer
des crèches de Noël dans les
mairies alors qu'il dit non alors non je
dis non alors je sais très bien que la
loi pas beaucoup entendu aujourd'hui non
je sais que la loi peut être contournée
on t'a pas beaucoup je sais très bien
que parfois les tribunaux administratifs
contendu donne raison au maire mais pour
moi ça ne se discute pas les crèches de
Noël avec la Nativité que je respecte
énormément n'ont rien à faire dans un
établissement public si on cède
là-dessus alors à ce moment-là on cède
surtout donc laïcité dans les mairies
comme la loi le prévoit et pas pas du
tout d'exonération de responsabilités
des ma qui tenteent de contourner la loi
on est au-delà de la religion on c'est
un fait culturel c'est puis j'en ai
marre on est dans un pays
judéo-chrétien alors à ce moment-là on
ne faitte plus du tout Noël on ne
prononce plus le nom tu rentes dans une
tu rends ta prime de Noël et puis on
prend plus les primes de Noël on ne fait
plus Noël je suis désolé ça va ça va
au-delà c'est de la culture il y a des
milliers de gens qui viennent juste pour
voir pour c'est jolis et c'est pas
quelqu'un voudrait lire un extrait de la
Bible dans la mériie je dirais non là ça
n'ah voilà mais là ça n'a rien à voir
donc moi je n'en peux plus qu'on est à
se battre maintenant pour fêter Noël en
France excusez-moi il a raison mais j'ai
un truc que je comprends pas Noël ça
existe depuis la nuit des temps on a
tous grandi avec Noël avec les sapins
les crèches les guirlandes et là tout
d'un coup on vient nous sortir que Noël
est problématique que Noël est
problématique que Noël est trop
religieux alors qu'il y a plein de gens
comme Daniel pour qui Noël en réalité
même si Noël prend ses sources dans la
religion Noël n'est pas religieux pour
plein de gens c'est juste le mot Noël
c'est une ambiance c'est un sapin c'est
effectivement des crèches et je trouve
ça malsin et dangereux dans cette
période où les religions dans dans leur
caractère extrémiste peuvent poser
problème de créer des embroules là où il
y en a pas laisser les gens fêter Noël
tranquille laisser les
crèches je le voulais
celuilà mais j'ai rien joueur de pad
vous êtes
nul
c'est pour le B c'était un avertissement
fais gaffe il y a un autre Nounour c un
avertissement Raymond moi je moi je suis
sur leur ligne de conduite ça dérange
qui en fait Noël qui ça dérange qui de
voir des sapins c'est joli il y a une
crèche tu vas en mairie tu vas pas en
maie pour prendre en photo avec pas des
SAP c'est quoi c'est une crèche c'est
quoi c'est une crèchet existé c'est
depuis depuis 10 15 ans qu'on veut
interdire Noël les mères qui mettent
plus de sapin dans leur ville faut plus
de crèche dans les villes c'est un pays
de chrétien Noël c'est pas grave c'est
une fête c'est pas grave
Dér pas
j les je comprends g c'est sur le
principe de la laïcité qui est
inextinguible effectivement dans les
dans les textes de loi les mairies qui
le font
sont c'est depuis quand ça c'est depuis
quand le texte de loi moi j'ai non moi
j'ai regardé
queex comm c'est pas 1950 c'est depuis
2016 il a commencé à avoir le bordel
depu 201 au Conseil constin on fait une
loi 2016 Guillaume l'a dit c'est depuis
bien avant pourquoi depuis 2016 ou
peut-être que je dis des conneries ça
m'étonnerait pas remarqu mais depuis
2016 pourquoi c'est seulement maintenant
qu' qu'on commence à enlever les sapins
et qu'on commence à dire non on veut
plus voir Noël les mecs ils ont jamais
été des enfants ces gensl c'est super
bien Noël laiss Noël tranquille voulez
pas fêter Noël on vous force pas pour
revenir à ce que pour revenir à ce que
disait Raymon qui s'est plain de Noël en
fait qui se plain de noëlendu un
musulman un juif un catholique n'importe
qui dire Noël c'est nul on veut pas Noël
on VE
juste pour less pour le faire plais cade
c'est la bonne ambiance et justement
pour une fois qu'il y a une religion qui
réunit j'ai envie de dire enfin un fait
d'une religion qui réunit moi je trouve
ça cool et c'est pas parce que il y en a
plusieurs qui vont cracher sur d'autres
religions et qui vont dire et ben non en
fait venez on se réunit même pour
d'autres religions et ça c'est cool à
faut arrêter de cracher ce qui est
positif venant d'une religion regarde on
est sur un plateau de Noël on est dans
unem
pas une crche de la Nativité non mais
oui mais
cal alors moi c'est vrai que quand
j'étais jeune il y avait des crèches
dans les mairies et ça ne posait
absolument aucun problème il y avait pas
de polémique il y avait pas de on était
pas on se sentait pas stigmatisé il y
avait pas de revendication il y avait
pas de problème il y avait pas de
problème bon aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est un problème et moi je suis pour la
laïcité donc je ne veux pas qu'il y a de
signentatoire de religion dans l'espace
public je le veux pour toutes les
religions donc là là je fais un pas de
côté et je me soumets et je me dis ok on
dégage les crèches des mairies on les
met dans les églises c'est très bien
comme ça avec le petit Jésus avec les
rois tout ça on pourrait les mettre sur
le parv à ce momentl ce momentl dans un
espace public pourquoi pas mais je ne
veux pas que ce soit dans un espace qui
qui dépend de l'état voilà je ne veux
pas je je ne veux pas que ce soit dans
dans les écoles je ne veux pas dans les
écoles publiques je veux pas que ce soit
dans les mairies je veux pas que ce soit
dans les département c'est très bien
comme ça parce qu'après parce qu'après
il y aura des revendications en fait
vraiment Géraldine certaines s'am tu
t'en fous en fait' m je dis après il y
aura des revendications c'est-à-dire que
ah bah alors si on fait la crèche alors
pourquoi on fait pas ça ben non en fait
non mais peu importe je ne veux qu'il y
ait aucune revendication aucune religion
donc il y a pas de religion dans parce
qu'on le fait depuis 1900 on le fait
depuis des années donc on changera pas
quelque chose d'un pays comme a dit
Daniel d'un pays chrétien on changera
pas on restera avec notre tradition moi
j'ai pas envie de me soumettre sur une
histoire de tradition je rentre même pas
dans l'histoire de religion que chacun
fait ses fêtes tranquillement mais
certaines ma certaines mairies jouent
avec la loi d'ailleurs parce qu' elles
font leur crèchees à la fois dans la
mairie et un peu à l'extérieur de la
mairie parce qu'elles ont elles ont des
courettes des choses comme ça et là
effectivement là elle ne tombe plus sur
le coup de la loi parce qu' elle joue
sur le sur l'ambiguïé du du
texte fais ta
vie moi Mo j'ai envie de garder ma
France telle que je l'ai connu quand
j'allais à la mairie je voyais les
crèches quand j'allais dans un
supermarché à l'époque y avait même une
crch devant avec le Père Noël avec qui
on faisait une photo moi je je trouve
qu'il y a rien de religieux bien
évidemment ça fait partie de la
décoration illustration
qui la tradition c'est pas une
signification religieuse particulière
les fêtes de fin d'année on aime grandir
avec le sapin avec les cadeaux le kiff
bon voilà quoi c'est tout non mais le
sapin c'est pas religieux je suis
d'accord c'est païen on l'a dit le jour
le père Noël comme comme est déguiser
cyil voilà c'est effectivement ça n'est
pas religieux en revanche une crèche
malgré tout avec les roisages avec
Gabriel avec le Jésus qui né à le 25 au
matin là enfin à minuit oui là c'est
quand même religux Galine qui tu c'est
toi-même qui a dit que ça ne te POS ça
ne posait aucun problème à personne il y
a quelques années ça dit quand même
quelque chose de notre société et moi ça
m'inquiète et je n'ai pas envie de
C que du coup je s'attaque à
laavance G et Géraldine vous parlez de
la loi mais la loi le Conseil d'État
s'est prononcé en 2016 et à expliqué que
il y avait une spécificité concernant C
parfois parfis elle est
syst parfis non je te lis le texte le
caractère culturel artistique et ou
festif s'il est démontré voilà s'il est
démontré
parfois démré systématiquement il est
démontré systématiquement par il s'agit
de Noël à chaque fois donc évidemment
que dans chacune des mairies va être
démontré le caractère festif de
Noël justementr pas juste jés que ça
projette ça chaque mairie à mon avis pe
peut passer peut passer entre les entre
les les gouttes parce qu'effectivement
il suffit simplement d'expliquer au
Conseil d'État que par exemple
l'installation d'une crèche dans la
mairie fait venir x
visiteurs voilà et puis donc il a en
vrai pas pas de pas de réel sujet parce
que si elle est maline la mairie elle
peut passer ça fait 10 minutes qu'on
parle vous dites il y a pas de réel
sujet elle est quand même extraordinaire
on dit que on dit que tu t'es trompé que
la loi à laquelle tu fais référence elle
a été modifié par le Conseil d'État
d'une certaine façon puisqu'ils ont déjà
dit en 2016 qu'il pouvait y avoir un
caractère festif avec c s quand il a un
usage local qui fait que et tu sais que
en fait tout ça vient de la Ligue des
droits de l'homme qui à chaque fois
dépose plainte maie après mairie parce
qu'il s'agit de mairie soit de droite
soit d'extrême droite ou en tous les cas
classé comme T et et donc ils vont faire
de la politique là-dessus mais ça n'a
pas de sens mais ils ont le droit de
déposer plainte
parfois
qui fait ça qui fait ça donnez-moi so
est-ce que ça vous a intéressé tout ce
qu'on a dit pas du tout mais pas du tout
mais vraiment pas du tout qui n'a pas
parlé qui a quelque chose à dire
d'intéressant personne merci comme
d'habitude on va voir le sondage oui à
92% ah oui doiton moi je suis d'accord
oui franchement mais VERALINE non non
ouais mais Géraldine c'est pas pareil là
parce qu'elle voulit te faire plaisir
une fois dans la semaine
c'est très bien moi Mo je moi je suis
pour je suis pour à fond les fêes
culturelles
sinon je suis désolé je suis pour à fond
après il y a Gill verdz qui voilà qui
comme d'habitude voilà qui sacage tout
qui saccage tout qui saccage le monde
non mais c'est vrai qu'est-ce qui te
dérange-ce qui
dé arrête avec la loi arrête
ave arrête avec la loi on
par mais la morale aussi
pourquoi PLA
tu vois pas qu'en ce moment les gens ils
se divisent à cause de la religion donc
pour une fois que les gens peuvent se
réunir et on devrait le faire avec
toutes les religions à chaque fois qu'il
y a une fête ou chose de positif et ben
on le fait tous ensemble c'est tout donc
là on fait Noël ensemble on mangera
ensemble après Ramadan et on fera qui
pour ensemble tu es pas content tu veux
la guerre non mais c'est bon calmez-vous
là je suis avec mon
pote des cadeau calmez-vous je suis avec
mon poteescend deux étages là direct
viens frérot on se barre on se barre
d'ici ils aiment pas Noël viens
[Applaudissements]
pas Noël il aiment pas Noël on se barre
d'ici je'ai je t'ai connu plus grand
toi c'est an le Père Noël ou non mais
moi j'ai strictement rien du tout contre
la religion catholique c'est parfait
c'est juste un chien Gal oui si vous
voulez mais mais mais dans le débat je
ne comprends pas image elle est très
belle mais derrière vous mais elle n'a
rien à faire dans une mairie qui est un
édifice
public qui sont d'ailleurs en partie
financé par l'argent public puiss
s'agacer de ce genre de chos c'est
franchement pas je je c'est perdre son
temps ce sont des gens qui ont plein de
combat àis raisonc mais ils ont plein de
fois raison ils ont plein de combat à
mener notamment sur des gens qui sont
emprisonnés à travers le monde mais
franchement venir s'énerver sur
l'organisation de crèche dans des
mairies dans dans le sud de la France
frç ça n'a aucun intérêt c'est politique
là c'est juste évidment que c'est
politique c'est que je essayer de faire
dire et puis arrête de jouer sur pour
pourer une réalité qui est que Noël est
la fête la plus populaire en France
c'est une réalité tout le monde même
ceux qui ne sont pas catholiques fê Noël
en a plein no ça fait plaisir à tout le
monde et toi tu veux les faire
ch mais pour autant excuse-moi mais pour
autant les les non catholiques lun pour
autant juste je je peux continuer ou on
change le débat arrête de faire un débat
S
non mais pour autant les non catholiques
qui fêtent Noël avec leurs enfants avec
leur famille et tout ça ne mettent pas
de de crèche chez eux est-ce que tu mets
une crèche chez toi est-ce que tu mets
une crèche chez toi est-ce que vous
mettez une crèche chez vous mets une
crèche chez Mo vous Metz une crèche chez
vous avec le petit Jésus et touttit
Jésus c'est un gros coupe alors le petit
josétit
Jos il a tout le monde le petit Jésus il
a le petit José il a le petit il a tout
le monde tout monde
moi je pense que la crèche fait partie
du patrimoine de Noël et c'est au-delà
d'un symbole religieux et que au même
titre que le Père Noël les gunandes les
sapins ça fait la meilleure preuve
Guillaume c'est que Yasser Arafat il
allait tous les ans à Bethléem Noël donc
ça n'a rien à voir avec la religion
voilà a dans les synagogues et dans les
mosquées pardon il y a des crèches dans
les synagogues et les mosquées non
non ça
dépasse une célébration qui est plus
large que ça et ça n'a jamais été un
problème jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait quelques
Politi euh les gars on va se retrouver
dans un instant